the microphone and you need about he
needs to record me do you see that I go
to give ear plugs welcome to the very
last lecture of this boot camp it's my
great pleasure to introduce Val tannin
from the University of Pennsylvania I
have a couple of things to say about Val
these days or not rather save these
years we've been working on the database
theory has made numerous contributions
including important and revisions on the
topic of his talk that the provenance in
addition he has produced a very long
list of very distinct with their
students including damn shoot you whose
name I mentioned yesterday but actually
one has another quality that makes him
very special for our program he is one
of the very few that the best theories
was very comfortable with categories
because if you can call it a call it the
quadrivalent in fact he did his PhD at
MIT and on lambda calculus corrected and
he if you got his web page you will see
that he has been successful in
explaining monett to his children when
they are toddlers so I think with this
you can see why you'd be right it is
very special definition of successful
yes thank you very much it's the last
talk of this boot camp yay so thank you
for still being here I'm actually
surprised so this is a slightly more
suggestive talk than the one the shorter
one that was put in the program which I
first gave to [ __ ] you
because this talk is about provenance
tracking and I'm going to try to explain
why is that important but let me first
say that right away that I was lucky to
have a remarkable list of remarkable
collaborators which appear here I should
also say that the first of these
collaborators DJ is actually here at
logic blocks in berkeley three of his
colleagues and here and he was here for
Fukien stalker but apparently he ran
away for this one he had to catch a
train so right so not clear what data
provenance is and it's like one of those
terms that were used and abused you
often have to see examples to understand
I will try to explain to you what I
understand by data provenance but you
might find in computer science people
especially from the systems side who
take much more practical and perhaps
less structured and perhaps less
interesting view of what they call data
provenance so for many in fact just
tracking provenance means just
maintaining an activity log you know so
whenever you touch something interesting
you record the fact that you did and
then you have a log of what happened and
that's you know there's happy with that
that's all they need perhaps but in fact
as systems try to take advantage of
having data provenance information
something else has emerged it has turned
out to be a lot more exciting I would
call it a processing based approach
because it has to do with data
processing rather than just data
therefore has to do is computation you
did arise in databases
you know since around 2000 and so on as
an absolutely fundamental paper was
written by Peter Buena man was also very
influential in general on those of us
who are we worked on this topic and
Peter together with one shootin and
sanjeev khanna wrote a paper they
changed somehow the perspective of what
is data provenance i should add for
those of you in programming languages
who are now who know about information
flow approaches there is a certain
relationship which i would like to
elucidate formally eventually but i've
been liking to do that for so many years
that i'm starting to worry that they
will there be a time surely one needs a
student for that to happen and we're
going to be more ambitious about
revenues and i will go as far as
actually talking about provenance
analysis as in algorithm analysis and
then maybe this is a little too you know
too much hoots why if you want but let's
see what you think at the end so
processing based perspective talks about
some computation that is happening
between an input and an output and the
question of provenance is interesting in
those cases when the input is a large
collection structured in some way
collection of items so there are many
different data items in the input and
it's interesting you would like to
distinguish their contribution to the
computation it's interesting to do so
the output may also be structured on but
ultimately you know being two editions
we're going to consider perhaps boolean
things and we just want to distinguish
and the influence of the input on
whether the output is true or false so
the kind of questions that people
working in this area would ask
themselves like this so they might ask
well which of all these input items are
used in producing a gift
an output item so we just go and one of
these things here we say well this is in
the output well which of those perhaps
not all of them if it's going to be
interesting then certainly not all of
them have actually have been used when
we produce the certain output and this
is essentially the log based approach
and it's somewhat boring but it figures
you know in my various slides as which
provenance more interesting one which is
the one that I alluded to in the
previous slide is a question that says
why is a given in item in the output and
this is different from which inputs
contributed because there could be
perhaps alternative reasons involving
different subsets of the input and an
even more comprehensive way to
understand what's going on could be
called how how were all those input
items and the various subgroups of them
that made an imporant how are they used
to produce a given output item and this
is a little vague when I say how because
clearly can mean anything and hopefully
we will clarify so now that we
understand these kind of questions I
would like to be a little more specific
in talking about two classes of
applications that we've identified so
far in this area let's call the first
class causal analysis and you'll see
what I mean so consider an output item
below and the first one is deletion
propagation so suppose some of the input
items disappear are deleted does little
Oh still stay in the output or does it
disappear too so this is very old you
know it's an instantiation of a very old
problem causality is understood by
counter
Jose so if some of the input I items are
such that the disappearance causes the
disappearance of 0 from the output
they're called counterfactuals another
more practical so this is practical too
because we do do they need to make
changes the database a very practical
question in science nowadays is is trust
and the simplest form of trust is binary
and some of the you can say some of the
input items are trusted and some are not
trusted and then here is an output item
can it be obtained only from trusted
items or every way of obtaining it is
from involving some untrusted items
you'd like to know another it doesn't
look like it has much to do with the
previous but with the access control so
suppose that you don't have uniform
access to the input items there is a
clearance procedure for each one of them
like some are public and some are top
secret and what have you and now well if
I look at a certain output item what
should my clearance be to be able to
read it to look at it that's also
provenance problem and then the one that
for Kieran actually discussed in some
detail so look at this item are always
in the output that's a probabilistic
event and if you have some probability
distribution on the input well what's
the probability that that Oh actually
ends up in the output so this is not all
and very interestingly more is has been
asked from provenance which I would call
quantitative analysis so one would be
cost you know sometimes data has cost
and you would like to you know if your
input items have different costs you'd
like to figure out the cost of actually
of a given output I'd
another interesting application is you
refine the binary trust to let's call it
confidence score non-binary trust so
instead of sort of knowing whether you
track instead of assuming whether you
trust or don't trust an input item you
just say well I have confidence point
three in this one and confidence point
nine in this one and then watch
confidence should i have in this
particular output item so that's already
plenty for me to justify that data
provenance can be used in interesting
ways and what I would like to since we
have already a whole bunch of different
application would like to post it as a
critical test for what we will be
exemplifying is that we would like to
compute provenance basically once the
same provenance and then specialized it
to somehow be able to answer any of
those five questions or maybe several of
those questions or questions like those
some of these questions are more than
one question if you think about so
that's a that's a critical test that
will be fulfilled by will be passed by
what I will show you now I'm going to
throw a teaser at you although i'm not
going to show you formally how to deal
with these things here is a problem that
we all know is you know shortest path so
the shortest path from A to F is ACEF
but then you ask questions like what if
a certain edge like C is down what
happens then what's the next shortest
path what happens then what if I don't
have clearance to use some edges you
know like they goes through forbidden
territory what if C is down with some
probability because it's maintained by
some lousy maintenance crew what if I
trust edges the different confidence
course what would be the confidence code
for my shortest path and it turns out
that in some sense this can be seen as a
special kind of X
the data log problem and although i'm
not going to show in this talk it can be
handled with the methods that actually i
will describe so the key to our approach
is somewhat philosophical and i do hope
that here you know the kind of stuff
that samsung likes and that i hope to
talk to him about is because here also
there seems to be there seem to be some
some fundamental aspects of information
that are at play and it would be
fascinating to know whether there are
parallels in say what he's doing so the
key is to distinguish two ways of using
data so we consume the data items for
the input from the input and we notice
that as we consume them we do it in two
different ways one is a call what I call
a joint way in other words I use to data
items actually together more than two
perhaps I use them together and that's
kind of like keeping a log but the
equally important is to consider when I
can use data items alternatively so I
get the same result but I can use it
obtain it through various alternatives
and this is essential for instance when
you try to reason about trust because it
would be nice to know that I can still
trust something even though some of the
ways of getting it are bad and untrusted
low confidence what have you but there
may be others that are acceptable so in
the end we'd like this to find always in
groups of input items the for how many
times the items i use and all that so
all that was general but now we're going
to look in specifically at what happens
with processing of databases
specifically relational databases i will
start with goes and in relational
databases we have these queries of the
kind that Pokemon has lectured about we
call the result of a query sometimes
you doesn't matter but so here is a very
tight example that has an input and what
are the input items here and what are
the output items obviously a nice
granularity to work with would be the
tuples in relational databases so if i
look at this output item 0 which is this
tuple d i may ask well what's the
provenance of this output item in terms
of the different input items so the key
that the second sort of salient aspect
of our approach is that provenance is
going to be computed by propagating
annotations and as we have sort of
implicitly discussed about the
provenance of a data item here we're
going to make it explicit and actually
consider for instance a tuple like ABC
to be labeled or annotated with a
particular provenance p and an operation
like join which involves two tuples if
you recall can be annotated by some kind
of combination of the annotations of the
two tuples that were combined and for
the moment we're going to stay
completely abstract and I'm just going
to use a nerdy Atlantic operate or x
here but I don't necessarily mean that
this is multiplication it's just an
abstract operation and what we see here
is an instantiation of what I call
before joint use of the data when you
join you use or in particular Cartesian
product you use both provenances at the
same time that is this other way of
propagating annotations which for
example comes about in unions of
relations where you may have the same
tuple in two relations and when you take
the Union that tuple is
corded there and its provenance is
another combination of the provenances
of that tuple in the previous relations
and here I hear there is a different
operation going to denote it by plus and
this is an example of alternative use of
data ABC is here either from the first
relation or from the other and I record
this with plus interestingly the
projection operation that was another
fundamental ingredient of relational
databases is also an instantiation of
this plus so if you have for example a
projection which you get rid of the sea
column it can happen that the rest of
the tuples are in fact the same a be
well a B ends up in the result but now
here we record a combination of the
provenances of all the input tuples they
contributed but what combination the
alternative views combination yes please
design choice rated yeah yeah some other
kind of so you can think of that for the
moment the design choices are on our
very minimal I'm just throwing two
operations in in play and I'm just
saying well I could equally well you
know instead of using operations use a
set or a bag of PNR the interpretation
of projection as the the plus of P Q and
R it's just as valid think of it as you
know I took the a from the first couple
and I took the be from the second couple
I it it might be but it doesn't fit with
I'll explain in a moment that it doesn't
fit with the normal semantics of
relational algebra and I'll explain
exactly how yes what you think that the
pluses
yes okay so mmm here is okay don't worry
I don't have to understand what this
query does but it has a whole bunch of
natural joints and projections and union
and stuff and I would have loved to use
a less complicated query but I also need
to produce some provenances which are
interesting enough to talk about so here
is what applying systematically what I
just showed you yields there is one
extra item that I didn't talk about one
extra operation in talk about a net
selection and for that one we are going
to use multiplication with 0 and 1 this
is fairly arbitrary but it will work and
if we have time I I can argue this but
just bear with me for that so two
special 0 and 1 are too special
annotations which will now have an
interesting meaning and I'm just going
to multiply with them so somebody so far
we have a space of annotations I don't
know what it is let's call it k with k
relations which in which every tuple is
annotated with some element from k we
have these two binary operations x and
plus they correspond to union and
projection and so on and we assume that
K contains the special annotations 0 and
1 and now i can already give you a hint
so 0 you should be understood as the
annotation of apps and tuples so if you
want the tuples that stay there are
those in the support one has an
interesting meaning it can be understood
as a neutral annotation this can be
derived from various examples in other
words no restriction so from a
provenance perspective that data data
annotated with one comes for free you
don't have to worry about tracking it
it's always there it's like you know
given by God so what do we have here
algebra of annotations what are the laws
of these structures are you already
know where I'm going with this because
it turns out that to go for these laws I
actually looked at the operations that
relational algebra equivalences that
relational algebra satisfies and these
are not abstract equivalences they are
actually used in implementations in
optimizations and it says they're these
optimizers use the fact that union is
associated commutative that joint is
associated commutative distributes of a
union projection and selection commute
alala one thing that we usually think is
part of the relational algebra is that
join of a relation with itself and the
Union relations itself is that same
relation in other words desired
important but that's actually not true
for if you think for a moment it's
certainly true for the set semantics but
it's not true for what for kyon called
bag semantics which I also want to cover
as a particular case here and of course
equivalent quede should produce the same
annotations and that leads you to a very
simple to prefer a position that if you
want to extend relation algebra 2 K
relation algebra to the algebra of K
relations and you want these identities
to hold then this k + 0 + x 0 1 has to
be a commutative say meaning if and only
if it's a commutative same inning and
it's nice it's it's indeed a structure
like Samson said the structure that sort
of raises its head in many corners of
computer science it's actually very
useful idea so for every commutative say
meeting k we have a k annotated
relational algebra so we already
generalized reiation knowledge okay
let's first see what it gives us to
begin with so using just the commutative
semi ring axioms I whatever was
annotated by zero disappears and what we
get is polynomials what kind of
polynomials
multivariate polynomials who are the
indeterminate the indeterminate of these
polynomials are annotations of the input
of the tuples in the input so i can
assume that the tuples are there in the
input for some reason p which is
indeterminate but only in order to
figure out what the dependencies between
the two poles in the output and those in
the input so p RS are indeterminate and
now i'm what i'm going to have here are
these kind of multivariate polynomials
and the coefficients are going to be
natural numbers no negative stuff here
because so far I've only worked with the
Select project join a union the
so-called positive fragment of query
languages of relational query languages
in the claim is that this polynomials
captured remarkably general form of
provenance which I can explain on the
same example as follows so what would be
the provenance reading of 2 r square +
RS so that was a tuple d that i pointed
out at the beginning how is this tuple
obtained from these three input items
and to r square + RS tell me that there
are three ways to derive this tuple d
two of these ways they are different but
two of them used are twice the third one
uses only I uses rns and once each so
the exponents correspond to the number
of uses the multiplicity number of uses
of the tuple the coefficients correspond
to the number of ways in which
essentially the same bag of tuples is
being used for the same result now we
don't have really time to decipher this
it's usually a little mysterious why
there are two different ways but this
quaint is complicated enough that these
self joins actually
different self joints in different parts
of the query that yields this tuple so
good things these provenance polynomials
have polynomial size it's an interesting
coincidence and therefore our PDA and RP
time computable and i hastened to add
this is data complexity because you will
complain that we didn't positively
relational algebra right oh yes I'm
still I'm still in positive relational
algebra when you go to data log this is
not true anymore and the the size can be
exponential in this in the size of the
query but in terms of data complexity
they are P done computable enough there
for 40 me sighs now easy p time complete
i actually don't know what do we know
about the complexity of bag of the
positive relation arch brown bag
semantics I don't know either so maybe
there are there's a way to sort of show
p completeness there it wasn't a major
worry it wasn't a major worry for us
okay so deletion propagation which I
mentioned at the beginning can be
already recovered it's a low-hanging
fruit as they say as follows so if i
have the processing that i showed you
before and I want to know what happens
if one of the tuples in the input is
deleted for example this one dbe it's
very simple to delete it you set R
equals 0 and setting r equals 0 in this
annotated relation is going to give you
exactly right answer two of the tuples
disappear and that's the only thing that
it is end up so this has actually been
treated in some other papers in
in database theory about causality and
counterfactuals and so on it's the same
story but what's really interesting
there is is actually on somehow getting
a different scores of importance for
different for different counterfactuals
but this actually is true and we used it
in a system for data sharing called
orchestra so commutative semi rings are
there commutative semi rings which are
useful so well I mean if Samsung uses
them they must be but Samson only
pointed out to two i believe yes three
okay well as here's a whole bunch more
so several of the semantics that have
been different semantics they've been
considered for database queries are
captured here certainly you know the set
semantics and the back semantics that
was disgusting for Cowen's talk
something he didn't talk about he
alluded to incomplete data bases is an
old piece of work but still rather
remarkable when in 84 immunity lips he
introduced what we call conditional
tables which end up being exactly
annotated relations but the annotation
is from boolean with boolean expressions
and the probabilistic work that he
referred to that for can refer to
actually was preceded by somewhat less
deep work in the 90s just trying to
figure out what it means to do probably
see databases and you can say that what
that work did was actually to label the
the tuples with events they've entered
the tuple is in and just sort of
calculating also using boolean
expressions of course calculating how
the output events depend on the input
events from which you then move on and
compute probabilities much more
interesting is the use of simmering for
application in other words
in particular same earrings we can get
interesting applications of provenance
by evaluating by specializing the
provenance to this particular same
earrings and of course the binary trust
which is really the same as the boolean
you can claim that multiplicities an
application I suppose this one is a very
interesting application I I call it cost
here but in fact this is known in the
literature as the tropical simmering
some of you might have played with it
positive reals the plus is a min and the
x is plus so it's a little weird but in
fact it has gotten a lot of mileage in
applications to computer science and an
isomorphic sailing to the tropical sea
meaning this one could be used as a good
one for confidence scores confidence
scores as say meetings have two by
necessity bit different than
probabilities because probability
operations per se but what's really
interesting is that these two are
related by something the statisticians
have used so the isomorphism to go from
t2 confidence is actually e to the minus
X or some exponential minus X and the
other and in the other direction is
what's called negative root log and you
might recall the use of negative log
likelihood in statistics there's the
fuzzy semi ring I shall say no more and
here is a really interesting 10 do you
mean to do that didn't mean to do that
either okay
so here is a really interesting one so
this semi ring actually has simple
operations min and Max and it has just
just five elements but it can be
understood as access control levels so
think of P is public c is confidential
SS secret and t is top secret and if you
look at you what if you look at min and
Max they are exactly the operations they
correspond to if you have an input item
that is secret and you jointly use it
with an input item that is top secret
then the result should be top secret
because use it jointly but if you use it
alternatively the result should be
secret well then top secret okay and
this can be used and finally we get to
the same earrings for provenance because
the title of our original paper was
provenance same earrings and the
polynomials that you have seen before
are here so the polynomials actually
form the free structure here it's a free
community of general semi ring generated
by X but there are others that have been
considered and until the same inning
framework we were not quite able to
understand to compare them but once we
had that it was for example the which
semi ring which as in which to Paul not
as in which of the wicked west so the
which say meeting was used by so we had
all to compute something they called
lineage the buena man Cana in time paper
introduced something they called why
provenance and don't look at this this
corresponds to computing sets of sets of
contributing to polls so basically a set
of witnesses so each set of contributing
to polls you can understand it as a
witness
and then if you in fact consider these
witnesses with respect to minimality you
will find that some witnesses include
others and it's if you consider just
minimal witnesses you find that the
result is actually well well known
simmering the same inning of positive
bull monotone or positive boolean
expressions which is also the one that
you use for probabilistic databases that
folk even mentioned sadly this was also
called lineage more lately another use
of the word lineage was in a project
called 30 I shall not say much about
that so I kind of gave up on using
lineage because it's these are
mathematically distinct object and there
we go so Peter actually has a good
saying he says well you know lineage is
for kings some scientists use the term
pedigree of data lineage is for kings
and pedigree is for dogs but provenance
is for art so it's the most elegant term
that we can use for essentially the same
thing all right so the best way to
understand these different provenance
same earrings was actually figured out
by TJ green who is not here who was in
the other prisoner and what you see here
is also we refine this in some sense
later in another paper so here's a bunch
of provenance a meetings which I really
related in terms of who's the most
informative and who's the least
informative and as you go down you get
from most to least is your sideways you
may have in comparable amount of
information in them so I'm gonna
actually compile
what does indicate more well so the
comparison relation is purely
mathematical but allow me to say that
the a at the end but now let me show you
an example so you believe it's from most
to least informative so suppose so this
is a polynomial of the kind that I've
shown you before now it turns out that
if you consider same earrings in which
may you make plus side important or you
make x idempotent and you still go for
the freeness property you get this so
look at compare this information here to
this information here so this B of X
these are polynomials but you get rid of
the coefficients they are only boolean
okay so you are not really caring
anymore about the number of different
ways of that use the same bag and here
in this project they used something that
that was not counting bags and I'm not
quite sure how to use it but it existed
in the literature so we we compared it
there now the next step is actually to
make this one's I'd important than this
one times I they put the plus side
important and interestingly what you get
is nothing interestingly what you get is
this which is the Y submitting that was
introduced by Buena man Connor and ton
so here we have you can think of this as
each of the monomials correspond to a
different witness but notice that Y and
X Y are separate monomials and in some
sense why is more parsimonious so it's
not me so this expression is not minimal
so what you do next is you actually
apply absorption and interestingly if
you apply absorption to the boolean
polynomials or you apply absorption to
the
I you get two different same earrings
this one I mentioned before this one is
the free absorptive commutative
simmering where by absorptive
commutative I mean this axiom here a B+
a equal a and commutative is still what
we started with and these are the
expressions in the free absorptive
cumulative which I called for some
reason SERP of X and this is the boolean
expression so look how how different how
much how low did we go from all this
detail the information all the way to
just y plus X Z which is in it's also
very important because this is all you
need for certain applications and just
for completeness I'm going to also put
the which the meeting so in the which
semi ring this is a provenance XYZ you
don't distinguish between alternatives
it's sad so so each of these semi rings
well more or less each of them is a free
simmering for a certain sub variety here
and the application cymatics that I
showed you before are actually also here
but before I do that let me explain
exactly how the comparison is done so
the RO everywhere where an arrow me
exists that means there is a subjective
semmering homomorphism which is an
identity on the tokens on the exes which
are the indeterminate or as i call them
provenance tokens so I this is a
reasonable way of of comparing
provenances we believe and adding the to
the picture the application
homomorphisms so if you recall this is
the tropical semi ring so if you want a
reason about cost or confidence scores
and so on it seems that the right
provenance is has to be at least in this
sort of X
you could use something higher but then
you know you you have more stuff to get
rid of if you want a reason about access
control or about you know just the
boolean say meeting about set semantics
then this is the provenance if you want
a reason about multiplicity then this is
the provenance okay so this is kind of a
take home picture it will this was a
very animated slide so I'm gonna have to
work hard to uh nunna major to put this
on there on the website yeah I am my
finger is is a little too thick so all
the examples that I've shown you satisfy
the following fundamental property
suppose that you have a query and the
queries from a certain query language
and so far I've only talked to you about
the positive relational algebra suppose
also that we have two committed if same
earrings k1 and k2 and a homework ism to
compare them H from k12 k2 then the
following diagram commutes you take an
input consisting of k1 annotated
relations and you apply a query to it
you get an output consisting of k1
annotated relations if you apply the
same query you to k2 annotated relations
and you obtain this output then the same
homomorphism that compares the inputs
will compare the outputs so this this
there was an instance in your talk this
morning which was saying that something
is a natural transformation I suppose
you can say here that Q the queries are
natural transformation but which queries
so the interesting thing is that of
course we had to prove this theorem
separately for every query language so
the query languages for which we were
able to prove this
mental comparison theorem were first of
all the positive relation algebra
queries spj you same as unions of
conjunctive queries data log aggregates
by which I mean you take all that with
aggregates and with some grouping blah
blah blah but also interestingly for a
language that actually doesn't use just
flat relations but nested relations at
the very end of his talk for human told
you wow there's a lot more about this
but you know we're just not going to go
there to that language we can also add
something trees we structure recursion
on trees and that works as well and in
fact we did that because we wanted to
derive a result of the same kind about
the form of an xml query language called
xquery and we can do that as well and
there's more Universal 25 yeah what does
that mean Universal 20 partner just
fessed up yeah so I don't know because
negation is a big big headache so I
can't just say well its negation of
negation confuse you also need a
positive I also mean the positiveness
relation calculus oh I it doesn't I only
allow equality comparisons between base
types sorry this was a sort of a rather
specialized discussion when you mention
X cream you don't mean that now you
switched to a semi-structured thing you
just what I do but not not in this talk
but yes this is I'm we were able to
prove a similar we were able to define
provenance semantics in the same way for
some form of x square e unordered xquery
and prove this theorem for that
so the way you accumulate the terms on a
tree have you okay nevermind that's
something we could have microsoft yes so
an instance of where of that commutative
diagram is what we called at the
beginning a critical test provenance
specialization so suppose we have an
application submitting maybe access
control maybe confidence whatever
suppose we have a set X of provenance
tokens and we begin by giving each of
these provenance tokens the value in
this application say meaning this
corresponds to actually labeling the
input tuples with something in this
application same inning well then
because these are all these provenance M
earrings are free that H uniquely
extends so that you have this so H
uniquely extends from and I mean here
most of those provenance I mean it but I
don't know what happened with 30 and so
on but I almost don't care so these are
certainly the important program settings
are free and as long as this is a semi
ring in which for which this is free for
in a variety for which this is free this
will work and why is this useful it's
because now once you know it's a excuse
but so because now I can I can do this
computation of the provenance once and
then I can apply it in several ways so
you can then specialized it to obtain
for example uncertainty annotations that
you can use in incomplete data bases or
in probabilistic databases you can use
it to obtain confidence course you can
use it to access to obtain access
control levels or if you have a more
general provenance you can simplify it
by actually using another provenance
simmering as an application domain
I'm going to skip this but not that much
so I have about 15 minutes and I want to
throw some teasers into the discussion
so it is interesting actually to think
about how we extended these ideas from
that very simple case of the positive
relational algebra how extended it to
say data log and aggregation so I'm just
going to give glimpses and maybe reasons
for further discussion if I manage to
make anybody curious so for data log the
problem is that what you define the
immediate consequence operator for a
data log program p let's assume that
data or program incorporates what's
called the extension on database well in
k relation semantics you can actually
express this as a function from Kerry
Asians 2k relations because in fact it
is a positive relational logic
computable operator and now the question
is if you think of this as a function
from Carol to Cairo for which nice same
earrings k can we find a fixed point for
TP so we know we can do it for sets for
when case the bully ins it turns out
that you can also do that it was worked
out somewhere 25 years ago that you can
also do it for bags but what is a
general thing going on so that's another
contribution of the work that we did and
we actually identified a class of
sufficiently useful we didn't
characterize but we identified the class
of sufficiently useful say meetings for
which this works and these are settings
that were already used in formal
language theory called Omega continues
which means what so if you have a semi
ring in fact all you have to do
is have a competitive moderate there is
a natural relationship in say x is less
than Y if you can say x plus Z equal Y
this is a pre-order in fact if pluses is
the join of a lattice this is in fact a
normal order but we say that the same
inning is naturally ordered if this
place is boarded a pre-order if it is
actually a partial order and it turns
out that all the same earrings that
we've seen here yeah so it turns out
that all the same enix that we've seen
here are naturally ordered there was
that there are others who are not like
the 0 second boolean algebras for
example or so so this this this is fine
that's not the difficult thing to have
but now what you want to have in order
to get fixed points is you want change
of these of these elements to have soups
to a value bees and you want + + x to
preserve the soup so this is in the
spirit of the main teri and but it's a
simpler situation because we don't need
that much incidentally if you have all
these things you can also actually talk
about it infinite sums countable sums
always have an answer
I think several people i think i
followed which
so do we have Omega continuum earrings
yes so most of the same earrings that
I've shown you like you know BTW
confidence a even fuzzy is omega
continuous but nicely the various
provenance and earrings are Omega
continues some of them for very trivial
reasons because there is really no
infinite chain of ascending chain now
the natural numbers by themselves do not
form an Omega continuum anyway it's very
easy to complete them to do so you just
join infinity and you extend the
operational usual way and now you might
think that the completion of the
polynomials is just to allow these
coefficients too but that's not true to
solve algebra and all these things so
instead you need foreign power series
and actually this is kind of related to
the use of formal power series informal
language theory that goes back to shoot
sunbury so let's denote by in infinity
with double parentis square parentheses
here and this is now the Omega continue
simmering in which we have semantics for
data log and it has similar freeness
properties and so on by the way the
completion of just the bull ians you
don't need more than that so I'm going
to skip except to show you that well so
you see this data log program here on
that database just for fun I computed
the prevalence and look what it is so
this is problem these are the
provenances of the outputs and wow the
Catalan numbers show up here but it's
not surprising because what is that data
log program it's well it's a bad way to
compute transitive closure but it's also
very related to context-free grammar for
generating well parenthesized and dike
languages and so on in general though
the these coefficients are actually
going to be from any infinity not
natural numbers like here and certain
things are decidable for example and you
can compute given a monomial you can go
puter coefficient you can even go decide
whether it's infinity or not there is as
is well known again from formal language
theory one thing is not decidable is
whether all the coefficients are bigger
than one because that corresponds to
ambiguity of context-free grammars so
there's that relationship that you can
you can import some results from there
so that's that that was it just a teaser
just to get using well with how does
this work and and there's actually so
when you go to data log there's a lot
the math becomes a lot more interesting
a lot of beautiful things happen and
similarly when we try to deal with
aggregation the math became more
interesting so what's aggregation so
consider that table there and well this
is actually not exactly SQL but there is
a way to write almost this in SQL which
is you want a group every tuple by the
first attribute D and then add the
values of the second attribute so this
is this is the answer to this query and
now the question is how can I do
provenance if I try to do it in the
style that I just did it for for for
relational 44 spj you I have to put
something here but I don't know what to
put because the reality is that the
obvious desiderata which is
compatibility with setback and the
fundamental property which we will get
have a stumble block and the stumble
block is the polynomial size overhead if
you have a sum
of size air with n terms it may have 2
to the n different answers and the
provenance is supposed to capture all of
them and actually there have been nice
some papers that actually considered you
know tables with exponentially many
tuples for that but we did something
different so we did we chose the
solution inspired by linear algebra
although of course here everything is
semi linear algebra are not linear
algebra because there is no minus so if
you think for a moment the relations
themselves with Union and the empty
relation for Mac a semi module the basis
of that is the singletons itself and
therefore every relation is actually the
result of a union aggregation now I'd
like to instead of Union I'd like to put
plus so I'm looking at say real numbers
with plus and zero and can this be a
provenance a semi module with respect to
some provenance semi ring if it can then
I'll be able to do something like this
to write here instead of 20 and 10 and
separate tuples I will say you know a
scalar times 20 plus a scalar times 10
think of 20 and 10 s vectors it's a
linear combination I still don't know
what to put here but now all of a sudden
this is a reasonably polynomial size
expression the problem is of course that
this is not a product semi module but
what can be done is this we can do a
tensor product construction in which we
can take in general community monoid and
the aggregations like some max or min
are actually done in community ma nights
and embed a community mano it in a case
emmy module by constructing the tensor
product between k itself and M so what's
going on is really interesting because i
used to have none
and now just because I want to track
their provenance I embed them into a
bigger space and that's k tensor product
m and in this space I have a scalar
multiplication will play the role of
annotation and it turns out that i will
have the properties that i would like
there's one snag which is that you'd
like this embedding to be consistent in
other words should be injective faithful
and there are some compatibility
conditions but it turns out that in the
cases in which it is not out exactly the
cases the database people already knew
about for example we now that summation
doesn't work well with set semantics
well this embedding is not going to be
faithful in that case so the result is
this here we're going to have x + y
because in fact this is obtained
alternatively from those again that's
something to argue and what we have in
these tables here are actually linear
combinations from this tensor product
and they kind of opened up a whole new
area of implementing these things
because we need efficient ways to to
implement these nuclear expressions but
from a theoretical point of view they
stay polynomial size and I'm done but I
have to show you a table because so this
is this is time from for humans think of
the next minute as part of folk ians
lecture so there are a lot of other
extensions for instance in case of data
log the provenance actually can be
infinite but when it stays finite it may
not be polynomial size that's a result
of culture and Victor's on that for
example boolean expressions for
transitive closure can be your super
polynomial size but we found a way to do
it with circuits instead of
pressions what TJ did and there are many
questions about negation i think i'm
going to talk about negation in one of
our half an hour things but what TJ did
in his eye CDT paper is dissertation
this is a general paper is that he
actually looked at containment and
equivalents of conjunctive queries and
unions of contracted ways under these
general semantics where instead of just
considering set and back semantics he
considered relations annotated with
provenance m earrings and it was a
comprehensive study it was a
dissertation after all so these are
results that actually might be
interesting to compare with what folk
Ian told you yesterday incidentally so
this is from the journal paper
incidentally the PI to be hard and and I
you know I cooperated with that he put
it there because you know with it was
said to be so by luminaries of the field
but this is a result that the Fukien
mentioned yesterday has been withdrawn
so we still don't know but interestingly
if you consider relations instead of
with back semantics if you consider
relations annotated with polynomials
then containment is actually in NP so
this is an example of what the Germans
call flushed knack for words which means
it's a hard problem why don't know how
to solve it I retreat from it but I do
it by jumping at something that looks
more sophisticated it turns out that
when you consider relations annotated
with Sony no meals although it looks
like you know this is more complicated
than n by itself it turns out that here
we do have a home amorphouse theorem
this is not home amorphous something
containment mappings we certain exactly
properties and that's what gives you NP
that's also what gives u GI for unions
of conjunctive queries and and in fact
these are equivalent and interestingly
for unions of contractive queries for
which you are knit is around my Krishnan
show this is undecidable TJ showed that
the prod that there is a piece pace
algorithm for it by identifying a class
of databases of polynomial size finally
many so moduli some orphans is
sufficient to check those there is still
a gap there probably because you know p
space is a little too far from where
this might be so we don't know this this
may still be open and that's it so thank
you questions for fun yes a very way to
capture likely there's no differential
privacy using this car sometimes I don't
know but I hope so we haven't tried hard
enough
what if you allow just in accordance
with the Matthew work that's not exactly
a sh 0 in the conjunctive queries well
so what is their semantics right so when
you have relations with if you have
relations whose tuples are annotated if
you consider blue unequal you know you
that so you can probably interpret that
over every any kind of domain yes not
less than but just so we haven't looked
at that well here's too bad DJ is not
here but he might have why I don't
recall but with vaguely I have a feeling
that he thought about it but that would
correspond to your result yeah yeah so
as an extreme form of unstructured data
a colleague of four counts alfaro at
santa cruz some time ago did work with
the students quite practical work of
annotating wikipedia pages by trying to
highlight the trustworthiness sort of
different words and how trustworthy they
are or how reliable they are you know so
could this kind of the semi ring thing
have any role in that very messy context
of because there it's not just separate
tuples like sentences or argument on
occasion let me say that we have tried
to extend this work in many ways there
is even a paper long list of authors in
which we took workflows and try to talk
about provenance of data and workflows
and the processing boxes in the
workflows we made them you know white
boxes containing computations expressed
in pig latin which is a form of
MapReduce
and that was okay now what you're
talking about is trying to capture a
kind of processing which is these guys
did that is completely unstructured me I
don't know this is joseph general
programs so if you just give me you give
me your java program and you want me to
compute provenance from input to output
I I it's I don't know I mean I showed
you i can do it for a certain way of
computing shortest path but i don't know
so like the next thing to do is for
example to take to take kruskal's
algorithm or prims algorithm yes and and
see if you can compute provenance there
this is also sensitive to the choice of
the language that I hesitate to make the
one thing that useful is this this this
this classification of joint and
alternative views and I do believe that
that is actually fairly Universal but I
don't know how to apply it outside of a
specific processing paradigm maybe the
by combining with the work done in
information flow
in classical combinatorics generating
functions is such a long time to count
all the number of ways of obtaining
certain events is there any rolls and I
kind of think it I mean in some sense
you can see what we did in data log
there for that specific case as a very
particular case of that but the counting
problems that the design of the
generating function is always very
sensitive to the formulation of the
counting problem what we try to do here
is still uniform in the in the language
I mean as [ __ ] pointed out I do come
from originally from a programming
language of semantics background so i
don't know i mean sure I mean the
Catalan numbers you saw that yeah so if
you do it for the snow transitive
closure what you get something boring
the wrist area that's why that one is
more exciting but but that's implement
incidentally in orchestra for the
programming language is is data log with
school and functions and some stuff so
that that stuff actually works yes ok
well I think I think we all deserve a
drink after this boot camp
well as just on behalf of all of us what
I would like to say is the organizers
and include the speakers have put on a
at least for me an amazingly informative
and inspiring series of courses and I'm
extremely privileged to be here and
experience that so we thank you without
don't go